I'm beginning to sort myself out.
Thanks to you.
While I'm very glad to hear that.
I have a question about scheduling your time,
trying to make a schedule in a chaotic job with constantly changing shifts and
out tips or should I find a new job all together?
Well,
you know,
I don't,
I can't answer that Josh because I don't know enough about the details of your
life.
But what I would say,
and maybe you've tried this already is you know,
try to make two plants.
Okay.
Because when you're,
when you're trying to think something like this through,
you need to think it through in detail.
And so one plan would be how you would conduct your life optimally and organize
your time if you kept your current job and you want to make that as acceptable
and positive as possible and then make out another plan where you shift jobs and
you have no,
maybe a more stable working arrangement and then think about what your life
would be like if you had that.
And then because you've laid out a detailed map of both,
you're in a much better position to compare them.
And so,
mmm.
You know,
you might need to talk to somebody about that too.
But that's what I would recommend because it's just too complicated a job.
Like if you find that your sleep is chronically disrupted and you can't organize
your life,
the fact that shift changes,
no trivial thing.
And it can really throw your mood regulation for a loop too.
And I don't know if that's happening to you.
Not,
but that's also something else that's worth taking into consideration.
But I would say map out an alternative reality where you don't have those
problems and see how much better that looks.
You know,
I presume there's some advantages to your current job.
So,
and it also depends on what your options are.
Like how hard would it be for you to find another job and could you find a job,
like maybe the best thing to do would be to try to find a job that's better,
that doesn't have shifts,
you know,
and maybe that'll take you a year or two.
It's,
that can be very difficult.
But you know,
a year or two is a shorter period of time.
Often that it seems so that's what I would recommend.
So.